[Musique]
bonjour moi c'est kevin du fait que je
suis le seuil haut débit et managers une
start up et technologies du numérique
qui développe une plateforme de
management de l'innovation à destination
des entreprises des universités et des
finances et de l'innovation
on est située dans les yvelines dans la
ville de trappes et nous sommes une
équipe de six personnes
[Musique]
notre activité consiste à développer une
solution pour idée les entreprises
innovantes à mieux gérer leurs projets
[Musique]
les fonctionnalités principales capote
avec des managers
c'est le suivi des faits marquants dans
un projet et puis le suivi du temps les
deux qu'ils parlent consulter les
équipes qui travaillent et chaque fin de
semaine
ils reçoivent un mail d'une relance
automatique qu'il a dit ou fait
contributeur sur quels projets pensez à
mettre vos faits marquants de la semaine
si vous en avez r des managers appli
prise par but d'apporter plus de
compétitivité et d'efficacité en
recherche développement innovation aux
entreprises innovantes
[Musique]
on s'est rendu compte que beaucoup de
pme et tpe avait du mal à bien gérer de
manière structurée le actifs de
recherche et développement en général on
se rend compte que les formations
techniques capitale se retrouve parfois
de manière dispersée
le management de l'innovation dans les
grands groupes se fait de manière très
sculptures et ses traits carrés un essai
un compte rendu des faits une diffusion
tout ceci avec une inertie qui parfois
peut affecter l'efficacité
opérationnelle des équipes et à l'aider
[Musique]
je trouve que l'entrepreneuriat c'est
quelque chose c'est une aventure voilà
ces quelques pâles au goût de l'aventuré
laventure de réaliser de créer d'avoir
des idées et de le donner la possibilité
d'exister et d'évoluer c'est un pari
c'est une aventure qui a duré que mais
c'est formateur
[Musique]